THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD IS A LOT
GOING ON BUT THERE IS ALSO MUCH
WE DON'T KNOW.
WHEN WE DO KNOW IS VENEZUELANS
CURRENT GOVERNMENT HAS DONE A
POOR JOB FOR PROVIDING FOR ITS
OWN PEOPLE, AND A SPILL HAS THE
LARGEST OIL LARGEST OIL RESERVES
YET IT REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACES ON THE PLANET.
THAT IS BEYOND DISPUTE.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS UP FOR
DEBATE.
WILL HE MAKE IT MORE STABLE
COUNTRY?
MORE TO THE POINT WOULD IT BE
GOOD FOR THE UNITED STATES?
LOTS OF PEOPLE CLICKED ON THE
ANSWER TO THAT BUT THEY DON'T,
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
IF RECENT HISTORY IS ANY GUIDE
FOR NOTHING WILL TURN OUT AS
EXPECTED, FEW THINGS EVER DO
WITH THAT HAS NOT STOPPED THE
GENIUS HAS AN WASHINGTON OR
SLOWED THEM DOWN.
THIS AFTERNOON, THEY AGREED THAT
THE UNITED STATES TO JUMP
IMMEDIATELY INTO THE VENEZUELAN
MASS, WATCH AS RICK SCOTT
EXPLAINS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT OUR
PRESENCE THERE WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WAS DOWN AT THE BORDER LAST
WEDNESDAY AND THIS IS PURE.
HE IS KILLING HIS OWN CITIZENS.
>> IS IT WORTH HOWEVER STRONGLY
YOU FEEL LOSING AMERICAN MEN AND
WOMEN TO DO JUST THAT?
>> HERE IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
IF WE DON'T WIN TODAY WE WILL
HAVE SYRIA AND THIS HEMISPHERE'S
WE CAN MAKE SURE SOMETHING
HAPPENS NOW ALL WE CAN DEAL WITH
THIS FOR DECADES TO COME.
IF WE CARE ABOUT FAMILIES, IF WE
CARE ABOUT THE HUMAN RACE AND
OUR CITIZENS THAT WE HAVE TO
STEP UP AND STOP THIS.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS CLEAR.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT FAMILIES AND
THE HUMAN RACE, IF YOU WANT TO
STOP WE WILL SEND YOUR CHILDREN
TO VENEZUELA WITHOUT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT IT.
YOU WILL JUST DO IT ASSUMING YOU
ARE A GOOD PERSON.
IF YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
FAMILIES, IF YOU DESPISE HUMAN
HAPPINESS ON SUPPORT THEN YOU
WANT TO JOIN A SAINTS TEAM AND
EMBRACE ISOLATIONISM, THE SINGLE
WORST OF ALL WORLDVIEWS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE TELLING
YOU.
THE MESSAGE IS RECEIVED.
BEFORE THE BOMBERS TAKE OFF
LET'S JUST ANSWER A FEW QUICK
QUESTIONS STARTING WITH THE MOST
OBVIOUS, ONE WAS THE LAST SAMPLE
SUCCESSFULLY MEDDLED WITH
ANOTHER COUNTRY?
HAS IT EVER WORKED?
HOW ARE THE DEMOCRACIES WE SET
UP IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN?
HOW WOULD VENEZUELA BE
DIFFERENT?
PLEASE EXPLAIN.
WE PREPARED FOR THE REFUGEES
HAVE BEEN ASKED WOULD PRODUCE?
A STUDY BY THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTION FOUND THAT THE
COLLAPSE OF THE GOVERNMENT COULD
FORCE 8 MILLION PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY.
MANY OF THEM WOULD COME HERE.
LAWMAKERS IN THIS COUNTRY
PROPOSE GIVING THEM TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS THAT WOULD LET
EVEN A LEGAL ARRIVALS LIVE AND
WORK HERE AND EFFECT PERMANENTLY
HAS MANY HAVE BEFORE WITH NO
FEAR OF DEPORTATION.
WE PREPARED FOR THAT?
ARE WE PREPARED TO ABSORB NEW
MIGRANTS ALL OF THEM GREAT
PEOPLE NO QUESTION BUT MONEY
WITH LITTLE EDUCATION OR SKILLS
WERE ENGLISH.
HOW IS ANY OF THIS GOOD FOR THE
UNITED STATES?
OUR SANCTIONS ON VENEZUELA HAVE
SPIKED OUR GAS PRICES THAT HURTS
OUR STRUGGLING MIDDLE CLASS
VIRTUALLY THAN ANYTHING WE COULD
DO SO WHICH IS THE POINT OF
DOING THAT?
SORE LAWMAKERS CAN FEEL LIKE
GOOD PEOPLE AND IF THEY ARE
INDEED GOOD PEOPLE WHY DID THEY
CARE MORE ABOUT VENEZUELA THAN
THIS COUNTRY?
THEY ARE HAPPY TO SEMIMILITARY
TO SOUTH AMERICA AT THE FIRST